♪
(speaker #1):
Light and truth.
(speaker #2):
That's our motto.
That's our tradition.
A tradition spoken...
...by the voices of
past Yale graduates.
[Rising string music]
It is important for all of us to
appreciate where we come from
and how that history has really
shaped us
in ways that we
might not understand.
With your knowledge,
may you always be curious.
With your experience,
may you always remember
where you started.
The distance between
number one and number two
is always a constant.
If you want to improve the
organization,
you have to improve yourself
and the organization gets
pulled up with you.
Yale has a
long and honored tradition
of many people who have
made big changes to nursing
and the profession.
They are the ones that
created the tradition,
but you are the
keepers of the flame.
I have been fighting
climate change for two decades,
and people often ask me
how I remain hopeful
in the face of extreme weather
and grim forecasts.
The answer is simple:
I see countless solutions
spreading across the nation
and across the world.
Our view of nature
will influence the way
we treat nature,
and our view of human nature
will affect our understanding
of human responsibility.
If we only are looking for parts
of ourselves in others,
we will never really see
or listen fully,
and we will never really see all
of the aspects of a person.
Because we are always
more than one thing.
We don’t have to tamp down
parts of ourselves or others.
No matter where you are from,
your dreams are valid.
You have to have conviction
and completely question
everything and anything you do.
No matter how much you study,
no matter how much you know,
the side of your brain that
has the smarts
won’t necessarily help you
in making art.
Empathy is choosing to
see ourselves in another
despite our differences.
It’s recognizing that
the same humanity,
the same desire for meaning,
fulfillment and security,
exists in each of us, even if
it’s expressed uniquely.
Don’t settle for average.
Bring your best to the moment.
Then, whether it
fails or succeeds,
at least you know you
gave it all you had.
If you do your best
when you’re young
and try the hardest to fulfil
your dreams
but you don't succeed, then
at least when you reach 80,
you can say, I didn’t succeed as
I wanted, but I know I tried.
We need you to help us
create the new normal.
Utilize your
privileged education
and your flexible position
to propel us towards
a healthier society.
Don’t let anyone tell you
how to live.
You create your
own world now.
The world needs you to
create something new.
The gift my parents gave me,
the gift of no limits,
we need to pass along
to the next generation.
So...
Class of 2021...
(all speakers:)
What will our voice be?
[piano music] ♪♪